dès l'ouverture des bureaux de scrutin
il est rapidement devenu clair que la
participation s'annonçait exceptionnelle
les électeurs hong kongais se sont armés
de patience
cette jeune femme attendait depuis
presqu'une heure est énorme
elle tient à voter pour dire au
gouvernement comment elle se sent en
cette période si particulière en compte
c'est le cas de bien des gens ajouté
many people du showest corner
mobilité est capable
autant d'électeurs si tôt dans la
journée du jamais vu selon ce scrutateur
malgré la présence policière
l'atmosphère tranche avec la tensions
des dernières semaines les un blogueur
han kong et couvert les manifestations
s'en réjouit un chrono de la population
semble avoir entendu les nombreux appels
au calme
le chef de l'exécutif
hong kong est que willam s'en est
félicité en allant voter
cette élection locale est présenté par
les pro démocratie comme un référendum
contre son administration a ni sur pékin
en second lieu que ce scrutin a servi
d'exutoire constater ce canadien
hong kong et de naissance soit les
élections pour renouveler le parlement
en congrès mais pour l'instant mais john
smit
une ontarienne qui vit ici depuis 15 ans
retient surtout ceux ci de cette
mobilisation record de ses concitoyens
ici un libéro radio canada hong kong